This episode of DNews is proudly brought to
you by Subaru.
Sometimes, science has to ask the hard questions,
like, "How do you cure a legless person of
a foot cramp?"
Howdy everyone, Trace here for DNews -- Amputations
are more common than you think, mostly from
diabetes, trauma, birth defects and tumors.
Some estimates reach over 150,000 annually.
Aside from the pain and rehabilitation of
the healing process,
amputees have to deal with their own brain's
confusion over the loss of a limb.
Phantom Limb Pain is when a person feels pain
in a limb that they don't have.
There's literally nothing there, but the brain
still "feels" the missing limb.
Their toes might be moving, or fist might
be clenched tightly, they could even feel
like it's spontaneously getting shorter!
It's all in their head, but it feels real
to them.
It sounds terrible.
At the moment, treatments include relaxation
techniques, and mental exercises, but a new
technology from Sweden could really help people
who suffer from phantom limb pain.
A research group is using augmented reality
in combination with electronic sensing equipment
to give people their limbs back in virtual
reality!
The technology uses sensors and asks the amputee
to complete a computer game which "uses" their
limb.
It senses the nerve input from their brain
and responds as if they were using the missing
piece.
Once they've trained themselves to recognize
their virtual limb, therapists can help with
their rehabilitation.
A clenched fist can be relaxed, and the patient
can LITERALLY SEE the fist attached to their
arm relaxing too.
Augmented Reality Therapy works because our
brains are easily fooled into believing the
virtual arm is our own.
This is a new technique using an old trick.
The premotor cortex uses the information gathered
by your senses to keep an awareness of our
own bodies.
It uses this to determine if the hand in front
of it is YOUR hand or someone elses.
Scientists have known for a long time, given
absence of feeling or weight, the premotor
cortex favors visual information.
Thus, in the past, a simple mirror has been
used to accomplish what they're now doing
with virtual reality!
A mirror would be set up to mimic the missing
limb, and doctors found Mirror Therapy to
be even more effective than drugs in treating
Phantom Limb Pain.
This is yet another example of technology
being generally awesome.
Virtual reality is being used by therapists
to help cure people with phobias in a safe
environment, and help reduce fear, anxiety
and avoidance in PTSD patients.
It's even been used to treat burn victims
by helping them explore a snowy paradise to
cool down.
The brain is easily fooled, and we can use
that power for good.
But back to
augmented reality - what would you use it
for?
What if I could play as Goro from frickin'
Mortal Kombat.
Moving my FOUR ARMS using my brain.
Frickin' cool.
Tweet us yours @DNews or tell us in the comments
below!
Make sure you subscribe for more and we'll
see you later.